[Applause]
all right welcome everyone to our first
panel of the day on foundation of
machine learning it's quite an honor for
me to moderate this panel with all these
interesting new chairs so foundation and
machine learning is a very interesting
time now to do this kind of research
because we're kind of at a cusp between
amazing empirical successes which now
we're trying to explain with theory and
so there's a lot of new theories which
which is yet to be developed and so
we're quite happy to have chairs here in
Canada we'll both work on new
algorithmic development but as well as
theoretical justification and motivation
for for new advances in the field so
first I will ask each of the chair
holder to present yourself say what's
your research topic and about three
minutes each so perhaps we'll start with
you see emek one two three yes okay so
my name is C iMac affiliated with Miller
I'm at McGill
so generally I'm interested in
representation learning but but more
specifically these days I look at how we
can use ideas foundations that have been
developed in math and have been used
maybe in physics a lot including the
areas from in designing invariant
functions for better representation
learning so that's one way of doing it
in the past I've also been looking into
using graphical models for this purpose
the previous Turing Award winner
Judy apparel thought that
business where we're going to model our
brain basically because they could model
the uncertainty and they could model the
causal relations within a bunch of
variables and we could do inference and
learning in those settings but for some
reason that didn't take off now we're
using deep models mainly of course these
two are not exclusive but within this
framework up deep deep learning we are
looking for more sample efficient
representation learning and that's
that's what I'm excited about great
so Courtney well hi I'm Courtney pocket
um so I'm currently at Google brain in
Montreal and I'll be joining the McGill
math and statistics department next year
that's part of Mila I wanted to say a
little bit about my background I
actually did my undergraduate degree in
finance and saw operations research and
machine learning from there and decided
that I wanted to go into it and that's
actually how I ended up doing my PhD so
I think it's interesting to come from
Adam for background than most people my
research is actually in optimization so
I did a lot of my work at non smooth and
non convex optimization how to use
structure to design algorithms when you
don't have smoothness for instance I
also did some work in non smooth
analysis and large scale computing and
then more recently I become very much
interested in stochastic optimization
and the role that statistics is now
playing in obtaining good convergence
guarantees and how can we design
algorithms now based upon the
statistical guarantees and something
that I'm very much interested in it's
not really designing new algorithms
anymore but sort of trying to understand
what these algorithms are currently
doing so understanding the landscape how
is the landscape affecting the algorithm
sort of how complexity works and that
kind of
so thank you great thanks Gennady is
that correct or no it's Nathan
scientists say my name is Nathan
Sturdivant and I'm at the University of
Alberta before I say about my research I
just wanted to acknowledge that being
able to be successful as a researcher is
the product of many mentors family
members particularly for me my wife and
other people and so I wanted to
acknowledge that before I talk about the
work that I'm doing but my own work is
in the area of search very broadly
defined and I'm currently looking at the
intersection of search and machine
learning so I've looked in search at
algorithms understanding the theoretical
properties of algorithms and also how we
can create very large datasets and then
we're now using these datasets with
machine learning to understand what the
machine learning is capable of doing the
limits of it and how it combines with
search and effective ways wonderful now
Ginty I'm Monica I am the University of
Toronto and vector Institute my
expertise is mostly in computer
architecture and systems and as you can
probably guess I'm implying that for
machine learning which requires a huge
compute capabilities these days the most
interesting problems are related to what
are the hardware that is actually useful
for machine learning and beyond that
there are one of the most critical
problems right now how we can deliver
all this performance seamlessly for ml
people that's not necessarily a way of
all the fancy hardware that's beneath
the system that you're using a lot of
challenging tasks right now mostly
related to the fact that every major
company is trying to build their own
hardware so starting from google amazon
where we and other companies and
hundreds of startups you all want to
jump on this market and we all somehow
need to satisfies you know the ability
of other people to run on this hardware
great chris hi i'm chris Madison I'm
currently a member at the Institute for
Advanced Study
but I'll be joining the University of
Toronto and the vector Institute next
summer
I am interested in this sort of the hard
algorithmic problems that live at the
core of machine learning and in
particular the ones that are useful for
deep learning I've worked in the past on
probabilistic inference and gradient
estimation and more recently I've
started working on optimization and I'm
particularly interested in the ways in
which these these sort of foundational
problems of machine learning interact
and can inform each other so that's the
kind of work I hope to push forward in
in the next few years
great so I'm Kisangani I'm affiliated
with Millia I am a professor at the
Computer Engineering Electrical
Engineering department from university
level in Quebec City
part of the computer vision system lab
big data research center and so on my
field is vidya about I am feeling like I
always say that I am an applied guy for
the rotation and I'm a more conceptual
the article guy for apply people some in
between these two and trying to develop
methods that are kind of useful for
engineering applications I would say
right now there's two main axis that I'm
looking for is for like doing deep
learning but deep learning with small
datasets so be able to learn something
or to adapt models quickly things like
future learning meta learning and
transfer learning all these things is
something I'm looking for the other
aspects is also to do a black box
optimization to do like using methods
that can optimize over functions that we
don't have access to the unethical form
so I'm using probabilistic models on
that evolution strategies and so on
wonderful and Pascal my my name is
passed away I'm a new professor
assistant professor at you look Sarah I
came back for from friends one month ago
so I spent the last four years in India
in France and so I have a background in
computer science but when I was doing my
pigeon computer sight in machine
learning I learned a lot about
statistics to be able to study machine
learning algorithms in the last two
years at I was a research scientist at
the energy a little and I was working in
in the statistics team so I like to
bridge the gap between what
statisticians are doing and machine
learning computer scientist people and
so right now I consider myself as a
statistical learning terrorist and my
very specific subject of research is
such scholar NIDA we named the packet
Bayesian theory and it's it's a
framework from which I derive
generalization guarantees on the winning
algorithms and also get inspired by the
theoretical study to design new learning
algorithms and I try to use this to
study a lot of different problems on the
representation learning tools for
learning and others great all right
thanks for all the introduction so it's
wonderful to be able to learn what your
research interests are and before we we
will move perhaps into the future we can
start a discussion with a very CFR
question so why is Canada and your AI
Institute in particular the right place
for you to be pursuing your research and
I think I'll let the volunteer first
otherwise I will name someone anybody
wants to answer this question I can
start great I'm a recruitment chair
coming from the University of Denver and
the University of Denver was interested
in building an AI program but if you
look there at what they could build over
several years time versus what was at
the University of Alberta University of
Alberta it was starting three tiers
above what would be possible there and
so the quality of my colleagues and the
quality of the students to work with was
just an amazing opportunity and having
experienced both the u.s. funding and
the canadian funding system i have to
say i much prefer the canadian funding
system anybody else
I'd like to sort of follow up on that
this is related to the funding system
but also the culture of the Canadian
research environment I think it tends to
support curiosity driven research or
high-risk high-reward
search and I don't think it's any
accident that that two of the major
subfields of artificial intelligence
that are today generating so much buzz
deep learning and reinforcement learning
had two of their strongholds or three of
their strongholds in Canada and and sort
of sheltered those fields while maybe
they were not the hot fields of machine
learning and I think that's happening
today with work that that's going on
today and then and that sort of kindness
and willing to take risks is something
that Canada should be proud of anybody
else with Salomon's
in different position because in level
university we have not for staff are
associated to vanilla so I think that
the environment is interesting in the
sense that we have access to this nice
group in Montreal and we will develop
collaboration but at the same time in
level we have which exact kind of
tradition of multidisciplinary
collaboration and so it's after I would
say the experience of having like
interesting interactions with people
from other fields and we tend to have a
nice dialogue and it's I think it's kind
of really unleashing a lot Dede thinking
the other research is done especially
when you have some kind of I would say
apply view without doing applications
purely but having something that like
feed ideas I think I think this is
really interesting and for students help
them to get connection with many other
domains I think great anybody else wants
to add something so I think
collaboration is also one of the the key
point especially that that's one of the
attractive point which I tracked me to
Mila was this this this collaboration
with multiple universities and also with
like startups and the government and
everything so it's it's a very
stimulating environment so perhaps now
let's talk about interesting research so
anything in your field that you found
particularly exciting in the last year
or that you're you're you're perhaps
which we will look they will be talked
about at nerves that you would like to
share about all you want to go interns
I go with volunteers because there's too
many of you and I don't see you but I
can go interns if you want semuc so yeah
there is this this paper that I'm
excited about from max fillings group on
[Music]
gage equivalent neural networks so the
idea was so far the models that we could
build the way with the generalized
convolution to other domains was that
you needed to define sort of global
symmetry on your domain you could look
at a sphere look at a graph look at a
set and you look at their symmetries but
now there is this new paper that says
well you don't have need this global
symmetry you can apply the same sort of
ideas on general manifolds and build
this theoretical foundation to do that
symmetries so I think there's a lot of
use I don't think I would go through all
of them I'll go for people who are
excited about what they want to talk
about you can just jump Oh Chris yeah so
this is actually maybe not new work in
the sense of an advance or a new idea
but retrospective work that tries to
sort of carefully evaluate the current
situation and I'm thinking in particular
of some recent empirical work coming out
of Google brain led by Chris shaloo and
George Dahl on trying to evaluate the
effect of batch size for sort of very
classical optimization algorithms in
deep learning and actually as Roger
grosse pointed out the the sort of
surprising thing about that work was
that there was no surprise and they sort
of carefully clarified some confusions
in the literature and laid out a very
compelling empirical picture of what's
really happening on the ground and the
current culture and machine learning is
not quite as supportive as I would like
of that kind of work and I think it's
really important because it can it can
give guidance to theorists about what
kind of questions they should be asking
what kind of things we might expect when
we do theory and that's really important
as where as we're sort of developing
simpler models for which we have
theoretical traction I don't want to
talk about any specific
I want to talk about molecule about big
research direction so if you look at the
list of sponsors of your Apes you're
gonna see the usual suspects but you're
also going to see a lot of new companies
that a lot of you probably not heard
about like graphic or Cerebrus and many
others they all are now here is just
because they try to make an impact right
so they're all building machine learning
hardware and they got tons of funds for
that and there is a big a lot of
competition you can ask why is it
important for us as researchers well
it's important with respect to how we
are going to actually evaluate and
properly compare which one actually
worth versus not worth it so there's a
lot of media claims about one Hardware
being 10x 100x faster than others and
you really need to be able to fairly
compare what's better or and what
actually performing better for your
workload in that in mind there was a
consortium created called mo curve that
has both academia participants and
industry participants and we already had
several releases for training an
inference where you can actually has
results that you can compare and look
for your models as well that you can see
numbers that actually all companies sign
on and that includes the startups I
mentioned that includes big companies
like Google and Nvidia that actually
would had to have numbers and again in
the line of spirit that we said a lot of
people thought that one was gonna be
hundred of X better than others and for
architects there's no surprise there but
others a lot of surprised there's not
that dramatic difference claimed in all
this blog post about one being much
better than the other one there are
differences there are some nuances but
it's not as dramatic as people claimed
soon
something is not a specific work but a
bunch of work that I say in the last two
years just to make give some background
I've got my PhD in a very competition
applied metacognition I did a lot I was
like 50/50 between machine learning and
a virtual competition up to like five
years ago six years ago and then I
decided to drop this field because
filing a little tired of all the
heuristic approach of biologically
inspired stuff and then I saw like two
years ago I regain in machine learning
of evolution strategies and all these
approaches put population-based training
all these things like optimizing deep
networks for inference firm for
reinforcement learning with aversion
strategies so I was kind of skeptical at
first because I was in well I noticed
things and I'm not sure it will it will
it has a lot of things to do but in fact
I'm more convinced at it to see the
interest rate interesting so I think
that there is this kind of orientation
that is really exciting so I'm I think I
would look at it more closely because
kind of get me back to the roots where I
was trained during my PhD if I can just
take one thing and so I not nervous
isn't a conference that I typically come
to because I like to go to broader AI
venues but the field of search is
something that is over 50 years old and
it's very easy to say oh all the
questions have been answered but in the
last four to five years there's been
fundamental changes and our
understanding of algorithms and the way
things work in that field and so to this
audience particularly I would say
encourage you if you were thinking about
search to be I'm making sure that you're
looking at this state-of-the-art and of
course to be more than glad to talk to
people about that maybe I will put in
just an interesting line of work that I
think I'd be started by Michael bacon by
a paper that appears on archive one year
ago approximately and what is know now
as I think the double decent curves and
in status coloring the common knowledge
or wisdom was that we must not use
models with too much power to avoid
overfitting and yeah absolutely and
tarik a theoretical be sure that under
some circumstance in fact sure what we
were observing in different neural
network but you really design some small
example when we see that very over
parameterize models can in fact
generalize better and it's really fun
because it gives some small emotional
problem where where we can see the same
beaver that are appearing that we were
observing in the usual network so from a
scholarly perspective we can really
study these behaviors start off with
what I'm not excited about it works dude
I'm not excited about an optimization
there's this push to show complexity you
know to produce the best algorithm you
know get epsilon to the five seven
fifths I think you know trying to get
you know the best algorithm out there
without really understanding what the
algorithm is actually doing and so this
is something that I want the commute
like the ML community and optimization
in the ML community to move away from
and move towards more understanding what
is actually happening instead of trying
to produce the latest greatest algorithm
out there so that we can actually you
know better design the algorithms
themselves later on if we understand
what's going on then we can help design
better algorithms out there
it has everyone thinks oh yeah okay good
so there's a lot of you actually do
optimization so perhaps to to get things
a bit spiced up perhaps something
controversial I get a lot of students in
deep learning coming to me inside oh who
cares about optimization I just use a
demand what's the use of optimization
research especially when what we care
about is not optimization is actually
generalization error so what's your
thought of this on this the panel people
in general but yeah you can you can
start court national wants to motivate
optimization in the modern era of
machine learning or an answer to these
grad students come to me say I can just
use atom and fight torch and I guess I
can answer this question um maybe I'm
the most qualified I do optimization um
yeah I think it's interesting okay so I
go to Miele sometimes and I hear this
also that students are just like oh I
why do I care I just used atom or at a
grad or I guess they don't use a de
Graaff they just use atom and the thing
which is interesting is they don't
actually again this this is this idea
they don't really understand or we don't
really understand why they why these
algorithms are working so they're
working for a very specific reason and
an optimization it's not just again
about producing the complexity result or
come on say a training error but it's
actually understanding why the algorithm
is doing what it's doing whether it's a
curvature whether it's noise whether you
know you're you're getting more second
order information or something there
there's usually something else involved
the landscape it plays the role the
objective function plays a role we
forget this but you know you can change
your loss it's totally fine
your last function to make it easier to
optimize that's a completely legitimate
thing and I think that there is a lot
more to optimization in that the machine
learning sometimes glosses over it just
because there's a lot of other things
that we want students to know and so we
don't really have time to go into a
theory side of optimization which has
been around for I think like for quite a
while now anybody else wants to chime in
I just want to add sort of a meta point
on top of Courtney Courtney's point
which is that it's very hard to know
ahead of time whether or not you can
make progress and that kind of goes both
ways right you can you can try to
prejudge ideas and decide well you know
I don't see how this is gonna work but
of course that was true before ADA grad
and Adam were invented and obviously
they've had a huge impact on our field
so there's sort of a significant
uncertainty over the future and in the
face of that what you should be doing is
working on what you're interested in not
what you can tell today is gonna work I
can say a few words in addition to that
so from the system's perspective all
these new algorithms and all their
possibilities to change the objective
function hyper parameters is a nightmare
so whenever we need to make a comparison
against competitors say Nvidia versus
Google was and other companies
submitting their best results and all
these moving targets that becomes a
nightmare
so we animal proof to go back and forth
around how to make things fair and at
the same time not limit the innovation
and the best thing we came up so far was
the ability to steal the hyper
parameters from others so essentially
when the submission happens everyone
submits the best results but then it
turns out if some company asks just in a
wait not really like another algorithm
level right but it doesn't necessarily
mean that you know that a hardware
better software stack then the others
can look and reuse it in their own
submission so to make it more fair so
that's the best strategy we came up but
yeah overall for us it's the fewer the
algorithm the better the
I'm not an expert on there's algorithms
obviously but I have heard recently a
very nice talk but George doll from
Google where he made a nice comparisons
between at least some order on which
algorithm better than others if proper
comparisons are made yeah hyper
parameter choices is very expensive so
at Mira we also care a lot about climate
change in particular and so the amount
of GPU hours which have been spent
tuning hyper parameters I think that's
that's one place also where our good
make advances will be very useful okay
so you wanted to say something maybe I
would get back to the question about and
then and the like I think it's it's very
relevant for supervised learning where
cignoli kind of clear but in some other
cases like in aerial are like when you
want to do I prepare this optimization
you want you need to optimize over the
optimization optimize over the model so
I think in such case it's different kind
of optimization so there is there's room
to explore these things and I I don't
think yeah I agree that for like some
kind of differential models that you can
use directly some kind of backdrop it
makes sense but there are other cases I
think that we need to look at great so
also like one of the big point of the
Canon Safari I'd share program is to
train the next generation of talent so
what would be the the best advice would
have for students interested in your
area of machining like what can grad
students be doing now to prepare for
future kidding me carries in the key
media on industry that you would like to
share okay I ever thought oh sorry
ok I I find it really strange that right
now in AI and machine learning there's
incredible resources we we've been given
sort of a very long leash by many
different organizations countries
funding agencies and at the same time
the sense I get from colleagues friends
students is that they they feel this
huge demand to publish in volume to just
get paper after paper after paper out
and especially at the beginning of a
career I
think that's a great strategy so my
advice would be to follow your interests
to develop your sort of unique
perspective on the field if that's one
paper a year that's perfectly fine you
can make up for the volume later if you
decide you want to go into academia but
that investment at the beginning of your
career is really going to sort of
support you in the future so longer-term
view yes
anybody else um I can add a little bit
Chris's point so I think we're an
academia to take risks right so what I
encourage my student is not afraid to
take on the aggressive directions in
research like for example one student
that started with me about a year ago
came to me and said okay I think
backpropagation is just wrong strategy
to do you know optimization it's
fundamentally bad we're trying to
optimize it after that on the software
level but there is a fundamental
sequential dependencies there and there
is nothing that we can do about it so we
just need to break that dependency and
the problem conflict come up with a very
nice idea on the theoretical end but the
problem was that the whole century
invidious tack is fully not ready for
that so if you want to go take the
trials you need to be ready for months
and months of engineering and
optimization and eventually we're able
to get something interesting out of it
and between their stage of their art
baseline with backpropagation but you
need to have courage and convince the
student also that should be brave enough
to move into a risky direction with high
reward and high promise
Courtney and then yeah so I want to take
something slightly dim for viewpoint um
advice I would give to a graduate
student it's actually to take a class or
get some experience in communication I
think we're lacking and like science is
so we don't actually teach people how to
create slides or give a talk or you know
do a poster it's sort of ad hoc but you
know in other fields like business for
instance you know this is what they do
and they know how to explain it and I
think that it's extremely important now
especially in AI to be able to
communicate results to other people I
think it's we we shouldn't be trying to
make things look really complicated we
should be trying to make it so that it's
understandable to the majority and the
people out there and so my advice for
students out there is to you know take a
class in communication learn how to do
some of these skills so I would see em
sometimes my students when they are
starting a PhD maybe look at the trends
and try to follow the trends and I
always advise them to not go in things
that are too trendy because they will be
in the less in the crowd and will be
really difficult to mark your your to do
something that is woodsy meaningful
because you are kind of in competition
with big teams and many people I say so
what I'm suggesting to my students to
look at different things to be open to
be curious about the different domains
and maybe try to make connections and
and figure out maybe new topics or maybe
topics around the edge of the current
trend new topics but that can be really
I would say interesting and original in
term of of proposing something new that
is relevant but still not in the in the
spot of what everyone is trying to do
right now so it's not too anticipated
and I feel that sometimes it worked
really well and we were I was happy to
see that we in fact developed something
and then and we weren't a big that like
six months one year after that people
get into such ideas
that's that's we need to really try to
avoid doing like the others are doing
try to do something that has some
potential of being I would say
anticipatory of what's going on add to
the last two which is to say I would
advise students to be aware of the
history of AI what got us to where we
are today what are the broader questions
that are being ant asked and answered
and that can do two things as one it
just gives you perspective but it also
can help you understand what are the
ways that people are thinking and how
can we maybe there's different questions
we should be asking that are not being
asked and that's a place where then you
can make strong inroads or even open up
new areas and and understand what's
being done before means that you do a
better job of not repeating things or
understanding what mistakes were and how
we can improve on them in the future
all right um so you have all fairly
broad background so do you have examples
perhaps of new tasks in machine learning
that that has been identified that that
we didn't really think about in the past
or applications new tonight type of data
that you would like to share
for in the past Oh ten years ago was not
there five years ago yeah so so I think
the absolute new application areas not
specifically new tasks but application
of machine learning in for example
astronomy and cosmology is sort of a
more recent one that I've been involved
in in some projects and but it comes
with its own challenges for example you
get huge datasets but these are not new
new tasks news new settings in which you
define new problems more of new
applications so I'm not sure this has
been unrecognized or sort of so novel
and no one's seen it but I think there's
sort of a big source of untapped data
that some people are looking at but we
could look at much more which is the
data that we produce ourselves so our
source code stack traces of algorithms
that are running all of this data is
occupy is a very very small part of all
possible programs or all possible stack
traces and so it really represents
something about what humans care about
in the world and it has specific
distributions and we generate tons of
this data so doing machine learning sort
of to inform perhaps software
engineering or or basic algorithms I
think is is sort of a rich area that is
is really blowing up right now
ya feel that I think can be we need to
look at we are looking at it but maybe
not as costly as can be Stalder the
systems that involve human in the loop
you know we have a lot of data that are
about people who are clicking or doing
this thing but maybe if we are looking
more at the case where I really have an
interaction between the system and
people and try to do something that is
able to customize to be fit to the
person really quickly I think this is
something where we can really get into
systems that are collaborating and
humans and are able to get into specific
behaviors that are fit to the person
that is using the system that's
something I think we need to look at
closely
woody else
oh I personally interested in the
privacy aspects and the ability to do
essentially training at the edge right
so this is something that I don't know
five ten years ago was unimaginable
because the compute power was not
possible and right now people are
actually we talk about it trying to come
up with creative protocols on federated
learning or incremental learning at the
edge and I think that's an interest in
direction and application for me I think
it's gonna have a huge potential in the
future great thanks a lot for everyone
so I think it's time now to open the
floor to the questions from the audience
anybody would like to ask a question to
our panelists in the back over there we
have a mic or D scream
activated microphones the panels about
foundations of machine learning and I
haven't heard anyone say anything about
semantics if you remember at the end of
the sixties natural language processing
hit this brick wall called the
confronting the meaning of language and
well as a computer scientist I'm
extremely happy to hear you talk about
what might be approximation algorithms
and complexity and focus when you talk
about refining algorithms some of you
also talked about preparing students so
that they can interact with industry I
want to hear more about foundations of
studies so I haven't heard anybody say
the word logic even once and I watch all
of my deep learning colleagues
reinventing concepts from the 50s in
mathematics
pursuing I think the correct goals but
not somehow excited or interested about
what's created the foundations that
guide your Urist ik traces when you make
decisions like in guided search and
gradient search and all the other things
we do so does anybody want to tackle
that so what's your question
plus I have a question for you so do you
think logic is definition of machine
learning so so the question that logic
is the foundation of semantics okay
fairly and if you're interested in how
you're confronting the brick wall of
semantics and explain ability which is
the reinvention of terms which is fine
from a long history I haven't heard
anybody talk about how to confront that
very difficult problem instead it's like
the old joke about the man looking for
his keys under the streetlight it's not
where he lost them but that's where the
light is so I think that this is
something that serious that I encourage
all my new graduate students to do to
read a book any book about logic and
semantics to be able to guide their work
in building models automatically semi
automatically labeled or run late
betta supervised or unsupervised to be
able to make sense of the next
generation of machine learning alright
anybody wants to anybody want tackled on
it you should all be tackling that by
the way so I'm just gonna and sorry
sorry I just wanna mention an important
point is that diversity of approaches
and research is super-important so
saying that everybody should tackle a
specific question I don't think is
appropriate for our research field i I
think that's right but we had to ignore
the foundations of where semantics and
the association between meaning and the
world and the symbols we push around
inside of computers comes from and that
that's a trajectory that I think is
distracts us from what the real goals of
artificial intelligence are thank you so
Chrissy what you're going to see
something I don't think I can answer the
totality of that question but I think
part of the answer might be or sort of
the historic answer that the deep
learning community had a very specific
background and had some founding effects
in terms of what has been worked on over
the last five to ten years as the
community grows and that's natural and
that's fine but one of the advantages of
being a field that's growing is that new
people are coming in and so there's a
lot of exciting work that's happening at
the intersection of some of these more
classical fields and deep learning one
of the areas that I'm very excited about
is verification of neural networks and
here you can see very natural overlaps
you have people coming in from more
traditional fields informing us in deep
learning and maybe learning something
from us and I think that's the space
where these things are happening and the
kind of interactions we should encourage
as opposed to asking that someone
somehow rewrite their own history
good any other question been shy shy sir
yeah anyway I mean there's a lot of
optimization I mean here in the in the
panel and they I held that a team may be
among you that bothers me and I think
quote me express it explicitly saying
when the optimization is difficult don't
be afraid of changing the objective and
to me it sounds like you know if I hear
that there was a traffic jam on my way
to work maybe I should go to the gym
instead because I will improve the
optimization and just changed my
objective and it's not just caught me I
see it a lot in papers people are saying
you know a this objective a you know
zero one loss is difficult or k-means is
difficult but here is a you know another
objective that I can write as a convex
optimization and let's of the you know
optimize that but you know we have a
goal and there was a reason why we want
this objective and optimizing something
different is kind of maybe exciting for
optimization people by pointless for the
target so halfway answering your
question which is I do work with the
games industry and working with the
games industry oftentimes the problem
isn't even well-defined so in such
contexts I would assert that it was a
completely valid to actually change your
problem definition because maybe the
problem in definition isn't even known
and then we can work with that to go
around it but I do agree that you know
we don't always want to just completely
change the problem or ignore something
because it's hard to work on hard
problems you know are meant to work on
because we can you know with more hard
work we can make progress on them and
actually I'd like to clarify that in the
optimization feel usually the
optimization objective is fixed so it's
it's more a machine learning luxury that
we are able to change the optimization
or approximate it because it's not
necessary exactly what we really want to
care about you want to say something
more quickly sorry I actually want to
say kind of
that the optimization community it's
actually moved kind of more in your
direction also for instance I do work in
non smooth and non convex and for a long
time people are like I will never touch
a convex problem I never touch a non
convex problem let's always convex if I
it right but because now there's been
research basically in machine learning
pushing towards a non convexity people
are going back and looking up these
objective function and this is sort of
what I mean it's like okay maybe the
problem that we're looking at isn't
exactly right maybe we can actually find
a better objective function that's more
what I was looking for Thanks any other
question you know yeah thank you very
much for a very interesting panel and
while listening to answers to previous
questions I couldn't help so but think
about well objective of our field I hear
a lot of arguments about what's right
and wrong for example I agree that back
propagation has its issues such as chain
of gradients vanishing gradients and so
on but does it mean that we should call
it right or wrong doesn't it depend on
context and the same thing about logic
discussion and other things
my question is how maybe should we try
to define common objectives from
perspective of which it will be more
clear to say what we focus on and what
we need right now for example if the
problem if the problem is to do the
low-level kind of reasoning in neural
net that may be what we're doing is
appropriate for this context if we
really try to model high level concepts
then yes we need to take a look at logic
but I think arguing about what's right
and wrong
without providing well-defined problem
is not very productive
so here is my question like do you think
we could have defined like Gilbert's top
10 problems of AI for ourselves so we
would be a bit more focused and say for
this problem that would be the right
approach and that approach would be
wrong but not in general because without
context it's very hard to kind of
compare things do you think it would be
a bit more productive approach to
they're kind of moving the field forward
all right so the C for top 10 problems
of AI anybody wants to this I can just
give a short answer well for myself I do
have these open problems that I think a
few people that work closely on similar
areas care about but I don't think these
are just a stepping-stone and it may not
they may not be of interest to the
broader community at this point maybe if
you make more progress than then it
becomes more important to the original
AI audience I think that that might be
true for for many other people you're
you're focused on one specific area and
you have this particular problem that
you want to solve but if you're just
talking to someone else it may not seem
very high impact over a broad enough
that particular open problem so I don't
know how easy would be to define a list
of 20 open problems for everybody
one interesting thing is I'm not
familiar with other fields than the
Hilbert's problems I'm not sure perhaps
there's learning theory where they also
list open problems but I in less
theoretical field I think it's pretty
hard to identify these clear
well-defined open questions sure if
anybody else has something to say about
this great Chris yeah I actually think
well I think it's a bit of a feature
not a bug of artificial intelligence
well yeah what I love about it is that I
don't think the paradigm has fully
settled and the field is going to
naturally resist any attempt to do that
we could sit and try to do that today
and we might come up with a bunch of
problems about neural networks if we had
done that 50 years ago we might have
come up with a bunch of problems about
logic and and then the next geoff hinton
is gonna come along and ignore those 10
problems and possibly revolutionize the
world and i think we're not yet at a
point where these can be well defined in
a way that we can guarantee progress
towards an objective we can defend if
they were solved yeah and I think one of
the the characteristics of the field is
being so multidisciplinary people are
coming from very different perspectives
and also with very different objectives
and so I'm not sure we really need to
make all them focus on specific
questions thank you for your answers I
agree with part of them but not all of
them and I guess we'll agree to disagree
I think that it is possible to define
certain common directions and it might
be a bit more productive and I also
don't think you need to wait for the
next Jeff Hinton why won't you be one
just think about it all right I I let
their other person to ask a question
thank you who's the next one I'm just
gonna follow up on that comment and say
that think of it not so much as
constraining your choices but increasing
your resources so the typical way that
Grand Challenge lists are created is in
a blue ribbon panel of leaders like
yourself that then give reasons for
funding agencies to put resources behind
those tasks to increase the total amount
of resources and to focus on a problem
and the benchmarks around them so it's
actually a pretty good exercise to do
and it's worth investing time in great
Thanks so is there any final questions
No
all right so I think that will wrap up
this panel let's thank our panelist
again
[Applause]